these microbes these nitrogen fixing
microbes are special because they have
an enzyme called nitrogenase this enzyme
catalyzes the breakup of that strong
bond holding nitrogen gas together
freeing up the nitrogens to become
ingredients in more accessible chemicals
like ammonia there's one catch though
nitrogenase stops working completely
when it is exposed to oxygen so
nitrogen-fixing organisms have a few
options for how to live many of them
live in anaerobic conditions where the
lack of oxygen means their vital enzyme
will be safe and other organisms like
the cyanobacteria we've been looking at
create their own internal forms of
protection sequestering the nitrogenase
into special cells called heterocysts
you can actually see the heterocysts
standing out like special green beads on
this dilaco spermum they look so
different because they need thick walls
so that oxygen can't pass through which
allows the nitrogenase to do its thing